[Musique]
bien eu en débat sur France 24 13e jour
de guerre en Ukraine des civils ont été
évacuées de la ville de soumis dans une
nouvelle tentative de mise en place de
couloirs humanitaires au moins 21
personnes ont été tuées dans des frappes
aériennes russes contre cette ville près
de la frontière Russo ukrainienne selon
un nouveau bilan des autorités
ukrainiennes malgré une très forte
résistance
ukrainienne les forces russes
progressent sur tous les fronts en
direction de Kiev côté occidental les
sanctions sont alourdies Joe Biden a
annoncé à arrêter toutes les
importations de pétrole et de gaz en
provenance de la Russie un embargo
décidé en coordination étroite avec les
alliés affirmés le président américain
le Royaume-Uni de son côté stoppera les
importations de pétrole russe d'ici à la
fin 2022 et Bruxelles a présenté des
solutions pour réduire de deux tiers les
importations de gaz russe de l'Union
européenne des cette année alors où en
est-on en ce 13e jour de conflit en
Ukraine l'interdiction des importations
de pétrole et de virus par les
États-Unis change-t-elle la donne
sommes-nous dans une guerre des blocs la
Russie contre l'Occident Poutine peut-il
contourner ses sanctions à l'aide de la
Chine on va en parler avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Jean-Maurice Ripert bonsoir ancienne
ambassadeur de France en Russie en Chine
et à l'ONU bien bienvenue dans le débat
en face de vous parce qu'elle Jouannin
Pascal Jouanne un bonsoir direct de la
Fondation Robert Schuman également avec
nous Adrien 2 juin bonsoir rédacteur de
à la revue conflit auteur de la France
atlantiste ou le naufrage de la
diplomatie et c'est aux éditions du Cerf
bienvenue à vous également en face de
vous Jean-François dit méglio bonsoir
président de l'Asia Center avant de
démarrer cette discussion on va d'abord
écouter le maire d'Odessa lodesa c'est
une cité portuaire stratégique on le
sait pour les Russes le maire de dessin
Satan vous allez l'entendre à une
attaque russe par la mer ou encore par
là Transnistrie on va l'écouter c'était
au micro de Marc peyrolman et c'était il
y a quelques instants
militaire nous pensons que
l'attaque proviendra de la mer
parce que il y a une formation de navire
militaire dans la mer Noire de 9 à 11
navires de débarquement
et en cas d'invasion la taxe sera depuis
la mer
mais nous nous attendons également à des
bombardement
et nous craignons que nos défenses
antiériennes seront impactées
et retrouve tout de suite justement au
dessin d'autre envoyé spécial Gwendoline
de Bono Gwendoline bonsoir on voit bien
que le maire d'Odessa Satan au pire vous
étiez vous aussi à Mikola Yves il y a
quelques jours une ville qui a été
bombardée qui se trouve pas loin de ça
oui absolument alors Nicolas ifs c'est
sans km à l'est de dessin en fait si
vous voulez mikolaïve c'est le dernier
verrou avant Odessa pour les pour les
forces russes c'est pour ça que c'est
une place stratégique c'est une place
importante et c'est là où se situe et
bien la ligne de front donc à 100 km de
dessin alors à nicolaïve la situation
est très différente parce qu'au dessin
pour l'instant et plutôt une ville plus
préservée que carquive par exemple que
Mario Paul qui est assiégé si on parle
de dessin et bien c'est vrai que la
ville se tient prête vous avez des
checkpoint vous avez des barrages un
petit peu partout dans la ville la plage
de dessin a été minée pour éviter
justement et bien ce dont parler le
maire de la ville une invasion par la
mer mais à part ça c'est vrai que les
magasins sont ouverts les gens par
exemple quand les sirènes d'alerte
retentissent à Odessa bien ne prennent
plus forcément le temps d'aller dans les
abris donc c'est vrai qu'il y a quand
même un le plan de normalité dans la
ville de dessa pour revenir à mikolave
totalement différent d'ailleurs on voit
des centaines de véhicules et de
personnes venant de cette ville et bien
se rendre vers au dessin à mikolaïves on
entend très régulièrement des tirs
d'artillerie alors pour l'instant c'est
vrai que les forces ukrainiennes
tiennent le terrain aujourd'hui je me
suis rendu dans la ville de mikolaïve et
il n'y a pas de force russe dans la
ville de mikadaïve pour l'instant les
Ukrainiens arrivent à les contenir en
lisière de en lisière de la ville mais
ce que nous disait par exemple un
chirurgien à l'hôpital depuis deux jours
elle est fort heureuse cible les zones
civiles dans cette ville on a vu
plusieurs quartiers détruits plusieurs
bâtiments détruits à l'hôpital de la
ville on a rencontré des victimes
civiles intouchées par un tiers de
roquette qui racontait également et bien
dans leur village aux abords de la ville
comment les forces russes postaient leur
temps que les hélicoptères extrêmement
nombreux mais également à des soldats
russes qui viennent chercher par exemple
de la nourriture dans les maisons des
habitants nous avons rencontré également
des soldats Ukrainiens rescapés d'une
attaque de missiles de croisière russe
sur la base où il dormait plusieurs de
leurs camarades sont morts et plus d'une
dizaine sont encore portées disparus
donc on voit bien qu'il y a un effort
russe sur cette ville de mikolaïve c'est
la poursuite du front Sud là où l'armée
russe a progressé plus rapidement
qu'ailleurs et c'est également pour cela
qu'on voit tous ces gens aujourd'hui
notamment et bien qui tentent de fuir
mikolaïve dans la direction de dessin
merci Gwendoline Gwendoline de Bono dans
en direct d'Odessa en Ukraine Adrien
besoins on sent qu'il y a une très forte
résistance ukrainienne tous nous
envoyait spéciaux le disent mais on sent
aussi que effectivement toutes ces front
russe se rapprochent de Kiev selon le
général Burkhart dans une interview
donner au monde les Russes ont
l'intention de tronçonner l'armée
ukrainienne
en fait il sera illusoire de penser que
les Russes sont planifiées une guerre
courte de 3-4 jours peut-être qu'au tout
début de la guerre ils ont pensé se
saisir des postes de commandement
Ukrainiens de façon très rapide avec des
des charges un peu un peu audacieuses un
peu kamikaze mais là on rentre vraiment
dans ce que le général burqa a appelé
justement le rouleau compresseur un peu
le l'image traditionnelle du rouleau
compresseur russe qui va avancer
progressivement et on voit que les
Russes par contre c'est vrai ou encore
des problèmes de coordination des
problèmes de logistique et que une
guerre de cette ampleur c'est c'est
énormément de pertes c'est énormément de
difficultés et l'opposition plus que ce
qu'ils avaient prévu et la résistance et
la résistance ukrainienne et supérieure
à ce qu'ils avaient prévu moi je suis
pas dans la tête des Russes donc je sais
pas ce qu'ils avaient exactement prévu
mais en tout cas nous
extérieurs en Europe occidentale je sais
pas si on avait prévu une telle
résistance de la part des Ukrainiens et
en particulier de la population on
observe quand même ce qui est comme ce
qui a été dit que au sud de l'Ukraine ça
rentre plus facilement peut-être parce
que la population est moins dans la
résistance que sur le front nord ça ça
me paraît important de le souligner
maintenant de mon point de vue il
faudrait il faudrait qu'on arrive à une
position réaliste qui est de dire qu'à
partir du moment où on a dit aux
Ukrainiens qu'on interviendrait pas
parce qu'on a peur d'une 3e guerre
mondiale et une guerre nucléaire on peut
pas en même temps les pousser à se
battre comme ça jusqu'à ce que tout le
monde soit mort si vous voulez un moment
donné il va falloir que la diplomatie
elle reprenne un petit peu ses droits et
que on les ukrainiens et les Russes se
rencontrent et qu'ils arrivent à traiter
de façon honorable pour tout le monde
pour que Poutine puisse retirer ses
troupes et que l'Ukraine puisse aussi se
reconstruire on n'a pas l'air d'en être
là en tout cas Jean Maurice Ripert
puisque vous êtes le diplomate du
plateau le chef de la diplomatie
américaine est en ce moment d'ailleurs
avec Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée pour
justement revoir une sorte de cohésion
probablement entre alliée alors est-ce
qu'il y a effectivement une vraie
logique de bloc Adrien des un disait il
faudrait une diplomatie la France par
exemple refuse la livraison d'avions de
combat à l'Ukraine ça a été encore redit
par Gabriel Attal ce matin parce qu'elle
ne veut pas être corbiligérante est-ce
qu'effectivement il y a des dissensions
de ce côté là
il y a eu un vote à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies il y a quelques jours
144 pays en condamné l'agression russe 4
pays ont soutenu la Russie donc s'il y a
deux blocs je ne sais pas très bien où
est l'autre
la Russie a déclaré la guerre à la
démocratie aux droits humains à la
liberté
en agressant l'Ukraine une nouvelle fois
puisque nous sommes 8 ans après
l'invasion de la Crimée l'annexion de la
Crimée de Sébastopol et le déclenchement
d'une guerre civile au dombases qui tout
le monde l'oublie a fait des dizaines de
milliers de morts et de morts civils
donc nous savons ce dont le président
Poutine est capable alors face à cela il
y a eu un front beaucoup plus unis
probablement et beaucoup plus rapidement
unis que Vladimir Poutine ne le pensait
les dictateurs ont parfois tendance
comme vous le savez à vivre un peu
enfermé c'est le cas de Vladimir Poutine
qui vit en général
moins Unis on peut le dire
Poutine vit au milieu de ses amis de
l'ex KGB du FSB des militaires il
n'écoute personne il a sous-estimé sans
aucun doute et la capacité de résistance
des Ukrainiens et la capacité de
réaction du reste du monde il y a
évidemment des différences entre les
Européens et les Américains elles sont
relativement minimes de mon point de vue
je suis même au contraire surpris de la
rapidité avec laquelle nous nous sommes
mis d'accord justement de la
cobelligence dont parle la France elle
ne souhaite pas justement exporter des
des avions il n'y a aucun pays de l'OTAN
qui a décidé de déclarer la guerre à la
Russie ça vous a pas échappé donc nous
fournissons le maximum d'armement d'aide
d'humanitaire et d'aide financière
possible à l'Ukraine on accueille aussi
des réfugiés mais personne ne veut
prendre le risque d'avoir une bataille
aérienne au dessus du ciel ukrainien
entre des avions russes et des avions de
l'OTAN quel que soit leur nationalité
demande bien sûr
une zone d'exclusion aérienne oui mais
encore une fois le problème de la zone
d'exclusion aérienne c'est qu'il faut la
faire respecter pour la faire respecter
il faut tirer sur les avions qu'il a
violent et pour les mêmes raisons
d'ailleurs vous le savez on n'a pas été
capable pendant la guerre en Syrie une
autre gare dans laquelle les méthodes de
Vladimir Poutine je le rappelle pardon
mais ces deux-là aujourd'hui des
milliers de morts civiles sous des
bombes chimiques lâchés par des avions
russes et pas seulement si rien comme on
l'a dit Jean-François dit miguelieu on
parlait de logique de bloc Jean-Maurice
rippet dit non il n'y a pas vraiment de
blocs puisque quatre pays seulement
n'ont pas voté alors la Chine justement
elle fait partie de ces pays en tout cas
qui se sont abstenus alors vous allez
nous raconter ce que la Chine justement
est-ce qu'elle sort de cette logique de
bloc parce qu'on voit qu'elle a apporté
par exemple ce matin lors d'une
conversation avec Emmanuel Macron une
sorte et avec d'ailleurs le chancelier
scholls un soutien à l'action à une
demande de cesser le feu en Ukraine donc
elle diplomatiquement elle se rapproche
un petit peu des Européens et puis en
même temps elle a signé un vrai traité
économique et militaire avec la Russie
donc est-ce qu'il y a un bloc Russie
Chine ou pas mais déjà pour reprendre
les votes à l'ONU la Chine a été
cohérente avec tous ces votes jusqu'à
présent puisque à chaque fois sur les
questions de l'Ukraine elle s'est
absolument donc une nouvelle fois elle
s'est abstenu et quand on parle de blocs
effectivement ce qui est intéressant
c'est que dans les abstentionnistes vous
avez deux pays l'Inde et la Chine qui
habituellement se retrouve si on veut
faire des clivages un peu systématique
et un peu exagéré dans nos blocs
différents puisque l'un des supposé dans
l'Indopacifique et la Chine est supposée
être effectivement
la cible d'une certaine façon de la
stratégie en tout cas américaine de la
dopacifique par ailleurs c'est vrai que
la Chine est clairement sur une
trajectoire de rapprochement progressif
avec la Russie elle a fêté l'année
dernière les 20 ans sont traités
d'amitié le 4 février il y a eu cette
rencontre effectivement assez
spectaculaire puisque Poutine était le
seul grand chef d'État qui était présent
à l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
d'hiver et il y a eu effectivement cette
déclaration et ce et ce traité alors
elle refuse de parler d'invasion elle
refuse la Chine d'un certain côté je
dirais probablement un embarras il y a
un mystère autour de la communication
que Poutine aurait faite ou pas faite à
son homologue chinois est-ce qu'il a dit
je vais faire quelque chose vers
l'Ukraine est-ce qu'il a dit au dernier
moment je vais envahir et comme on le
dit parfois sitting y aurait dit
attendez s'il vous plaît la fin de la
très olympique mais je rappelle que la
trêve olympique n'est pas finie
puisqu'on est toujours dans les Jeux
paralympiques donc clairement la
trajectoire du rapprochement a été abîmé
parce qu'il vient de se passer néanmoins
dans quelle mesure parce que
effectivement
l'invasion n'est pas dans l'intérêt de
la Chine la stratégie chinoise ou alors
il y a peut-être un autre niveau la
stratégie chinoise c'est d'augmenter la
pression sur le bloc occidental mais de
ne pas le prendre de front en étant de
rappeler le la fameuse formule de d'un
chapoping même si ça n'est pas
d'actualité ce tapir dans l'ombre et
attendre son heure et là peut-être
qu'elle instrumentalisé la Russie aussi
on peut aussi se dire ça finalement la
Russie c'est le méchant et nous on va
voir ce qui se passe et après avoir été
sollicité trois fois quatre fois comme
le faiseur de paix peut-être on décidera
d'entrer dans le jeu international comme
le faiseur de paix en tout cas ce sur
quoi il ne faut pas compter quand on est
russe c'est sur le fait que la Chine
remplace les débouchés occidentaux il y
a absolument pas de complémentaires on
va on va y revenir là-dessus alors
Pascal justement Pascal Johanna l'Europe
fait face elle fait bloc face à Poutine
même si elle n'est pas totalement
alignée sur les Américains ce qu'il faut
noter c'est qu'en effet il y a une
réaction
vous pouvez peut-être pas imaginer la
dernière tétine a peut-être fait
solidifier l'Union européenne qu'on
voyait toujours comme molle comme des
Unis c'est 27 États en effet en effet là
on parle d’état la Chine l'Inde les
États-Unis l'Union européenne c'est 27
États et bien lui 27 États se sont mis
rapidement d'accord sur des mesures
économiques d'une ampleur sans précédent
sur des mesures en effet de livraison
d'armes c'est même la présidente de la
Commission européenne qu'il a annoncé
elle-même sur des mesures de rétorsion
bancaire avec le programme Swift etc on
va avoir des mesures énergétiques on en
parlera tout à l'heure mais en effet on
a une unité de l'Europe qui est un bloc
si vous voulez ou en effet Vladimir
Poutine on voit bien et l'opposé comme
vous l'avez dit de la démocratie et de
la liberté et bien ce qu'incarne en
effet l'Europe c'est la liberté et la
démocratie on voyait bien que l'Ukraine
regardait de plus en plus vers l'ouest
et de moins en moins vers l'est depuis
2004 il y a eu la Révolution orange j'ai
eu le Maidan il y avait des drapeaux
européens pas des drapeaux de l'OTAN
quand on faisait les révolutions en
Ukraine et on a peuple ukrainien qui est
agressé donc je comprends tout à fait
qu'il résiste et j'espère qu'il va
résister longtemps et qu'on va le
soutenir comme on a résisté nous quand
on a eu des autres agressions il y a
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
puisque en effet si Monsieur Poutine
veut faire la guerre et bien il a
déclaré c'est pas nous qui l'avons
déclaré et donc on a en effet en Europe
pas la guerre on a une puissance qui
s'affirme et qui va avoir des
répercussions je pense que la population
l'Europe a changé la population russe va
s'apercevoir que les mesures de
rétorsion européenne et américaines vont
faire mal non seulement aux oligarques
mais à tous ceux qui sont en Russie qui
nous sont devenus un peu le pays paria
et avec lequel en effet il est plus ou
moins mal vu de s'afficher alors
justement ces sanctions elles ont
démarré il y a depuis un certain temps
mais alors effectivement aujourd'hui on
peut dire qu'elles ont atteint une
nouvelle étape puisque les États-Unis
vont interdire Joe Biden l'a annoncé
donc les importations de pétrole et de
gaz russes on va écouter le président
américain
nous interdisons toutes les importations
de pétrole de gaz et d’énergie russe
cela signifie que le pétrole russe ne
sera plus accepté dans les ports
américains et que le peuple américain va
infliger un nouveau couru dans la
machine de guerre de Poutine cette
mesure a reçu un soutien bip partisan au
Congrès mais aussi celui de tout le pays
nous avons pris cette décision encore
des nations étroites avec nos alliés et
nos partenaires à travers le monde
particulièrement en Europe car une
réponse unie à l'agression de Poutine a
été ma priorité absolue que l'OTAN l'UE
et nos alliés soient totalement Unis
c'est vrai que le président américain
vraiment met l'accent sur cette union se
bloque en fait ce bloc des démocraties
se bloque occidental dans le cadre de
ces sanctions est-ce qu'il paraît
véritablement sur le fait que ça va
affaiblir l'admire Poutine je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas Joseph Biden lui il
a été traumatisé quand même par le
retrait d'Afghanistan qui s'est très mal
passé les Européens n'ont pas été
consultés donc il y a eu une espèce de
divorce franco-américain ce moment là et
je pense qu'il est soucieux sur la crise
ukrainienne de à nouveau unifier
l'Europe et les États-Unis et quand on
dit que l'Europe signifie oui elle
signifie mais avec les États-Unis donc
c'est plutôt un bloc euro Atlantique
auquel on assiste pas seulement européen
c'est historique ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui non parce que enfin c'est
historique dans le sens oui c'est
historique parce que c'est le blog de la
guerre froide qu'on retrouve finalement
c'est une nouvelle guerre froide ou une
reprise de la guerre froide Vladimir
Poutine disait en fait les Américains
croient avoir gagné la guerre froide
mais la guerre froide ne s'est pas
terminée parce qu'elle continue donc le
Poutine relève le gant entre guillemets
et dit mais la guerre froide elle
continue et la logique des blocs lui
l'accepte très volontiers et avec l'aide
de la Chine c'est peut-être ça qui est
nouveau par rapport à la fin de la
guerre froide
que nous avons connu dans les années 70
et 80 ou la Chine était détachée de la
Russie là on a la Chine et la Russie qui
sont avec des nuances qu'on a rappelé
évidemment monsieur tout à l'heure mais
qui sont globalement unis face au bloc
euro-atlantique on voit bien sur les sur
les sanctions qui ont été votées ou les
votes à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
pardon c'est que il y a quand même un
certain nombre de pays qui se sont
abstenus un de voter des sanctions qui
se sont pas groupés derrière
voilà
pays ça permet de relativiser aussi oui
de suivi euro Atlantique dans ces
régions là on observe effectivement en
Amérique du Sud Amérique du Nord Europe
occidentale mais pour le reste du monde
c'est plus compliqué c'est peut-être là
que par rapport à la précédente guerre
froide on est des nuances c'est que
aujourd'hui l'économie mondiale elle est
davantage en Asie et donc il y a un jeu
de puissance qui est beaucoup plus
subtil et beaucoup plus équilibré que ce
qu'on a connu entre 45 et 90
je voudrais juste réagir sur deux trois
points d'abord je voudrais saluer ça a
été mentionné en passant le courage
extraordinaire des Russes qui descendent
dans la rue pour dénoncer la guerre de
Vladimir Poutine parce que quand la
télévision russe vous annonce qui a eu
10 000 arrestations ça veut dire qu'il y
avait dans les rues de Moscou de
Saint-Pétersbourg et d'autres villes des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
c'est à dire probablement qu'on n'avait
pas vu ça depuis les manifestations de
la place bolote Naïa en 2012 contre
l'arrêt élection jugée frauduleuse de
Vladimir Poutine ces gens risquent des
années dans les camps dans les camps
c'est pas seulement des prisons il faut
se souvenir de du sort de navalnie et
d'autres bien deuxième chose que je
voudrais dire sur la Chine on peut
fabriquer des alliances moi j'ai vu
pendant que j'étais ambassadeur en Chine
les Chinois et les rues en Russie les
Chinois signaient des milliards de
dollars d'investissement ils n'ont
jamais donné le moindre dollar pour
mettre en œuvre ses projets le
doublement du Transsibérien le
doublement du gazoduc parce que les
Chinois profondément se méfient de la
Russie bien quand les Chinois
s'abstiennent ou des fonds des
déclarations vous savez les habitués de
la Chine le savent plus la Chine parle
en général moins elle agit il faut que
les choses soient claires la Chine
regarde ce qui se passe pourquoi parce
qu'elle a des intérêts en Ukraine très
clair qu'elle est en train de perdre et
surtout parce qu'elle a si justement à
cette
resolidification de l'Europe qu'elle ne
souhaitait évidemment pas et puis elle
pense toujours à Taïwan et donc elle
regarde comment nous réagissons pardon
un dernier point moi je ne crois pas du
tout à un axe euros-atlantique ce à quoi
nous sommes en train d'assister c'est à
la victoire progressive à la
constitution progressive de cette Europe
autonome stratégiquement sur le plan
militaire sur le plan oui déjà il s'est
passé en trois ans une évolution
incroyable et aujourd'hui quand on dit
que l'Europe se met d'accord avec les
États-Unis pardon je finira ça n'est pas
pour d'accord avec les Américains c'est
pour défendre son autonomie surtout les
fronts et nous l'avons de ce point de
vue là la France a joué un rôle moteur
et c'est le revirement allemand qui nous
a apporté une bouffée d'oxygène
extraordinaire pardon et je pense que il
y a un phénomène nouveau avec Joe Biden
et il se trouve que je parle et cet
après-midi avec l'un de ses conseillers
qui est un de mes amis c'est que Joe
Biden a compris que l'autonomie
stratégique européenne n'était pas
nécessairement contradictoire avec le
respect de l'Alliance atlantique donc il
s'agit pas d'être aligné sur les
États-Unis il s'agit d'être autonome
dans le cadre du respect de nos
alliances la différence entre dans le
cadre de l'OTAN en partenariat avec
l'OTAN pour ceux des États européens qui
sont membres de l'OTAN ça n'est pas la
même chose et la différence entre Joe
Biden Obama et Trump pardon de maître
Obama avec Donald Trump sa parait
bizarre c'est que et notamment grâce à
Anthony blinken qui connaît très bien
l'Europe son secrétaire d'État il a
compris que l'autonomie stratégique de
l'Europe ne voulait pas nécessairement
dire l'affaiblissement ni de l'OTAN ni
du monde Occident
on joue un petit peu avec les mots
soyons francs et je regarde sur table
effectivement l'OTAN est renforcé par la
guerre en Ukraine qui a été lancé par
Vladimir Poutine ce qui est
défenseur
et ça on nous le dit à chaque crise et à
chaque fois ça retombe on sait très bien
que de toute façon lors de la défense
sera cantonnée à sa partie civil au
militaire sa partie humanitaire
sécuritaire mais
vous savez pas ce que Poutine va faire
c'est difficile de dire il y a beaucoup
de choses qui ont changé en très peu de
jours il y a une prise de conscience
alors vous ne le souhaitez peut-être pas
c'est peut-être que ça va être difficile
mais d'habitude
c'est la première fois qu'il y a une
solaire vraiment
qui va peut-être faire des pas
substantiel qu'on imaginait pas jusqu'à
une défense europ
la défense européenne elle est pas la
défense américaine d'abord un en France
vous pouvez pas dire ça vous pouvez
peut-être le dire pour d'autres pays
comme l'Allemagne et d'autres pourquoi
pas le dire parce que c'est pas une
défense complètement qui est
complètement vous avez peut-être oublié
que la France avait réintégré le Comité
militaire
dans une position très à pas et c'est
pas le problème de la France qu'il faut
voir c'est le problème de l'Europe
l'Europe qui n'avait en effet beaucoup
fait pour être sous le parapluie
américain avec des États neutres qui
étaient très bien contents de l'être
vous avez des États neutres aujourd'hui
qui quand même se posent la question
Finlande et suède de savoir ce qu'ils
vont rester neutres c'est quand même pas
inintéressant l'Allemagne qui fait un
grand revirement sur la défense compte
tenu de ce qui était la deuxième guerre
mondiale et vous avez déjà sur le papier
avant avant l'Ukraine des choses qui
étaient sur la table l'autonomie
stratégique la boussole stratégique
c'est des petits éléments mais petits
éléments l'Europe elle a toujours marché
comme ça elle a pas fait de grands
basculement et petit donc vous pensez
qu'il y aura une vraie autonomie
une crise de conscience que les
Américains les prises de conscience que
les Américains vous l'avez rappelé
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur plusieurs
présidents américains nous ont dit la
priorité européenne c'est fini donc en
effet il va y avoir peut-être une prise
de conscience que nos intérêts ne sont
pas forcément les intérêts américains et
qu'un jour les Américains nous diront
mais écoutez votre problème pas le nôtre
et qui aura peut-être plus en effet ce
lien transatlantique non pas qu'il
existera plus mais parce que les
américains auront à d'autres un autre
agenda donc si on fait pour l'instant on
a l'impression on va voir quelque chose
il faut avoir une indépendance ça va pas
se faire facilement mais il y a en effet
des projets sur la table et on voit bien
que sur cette question on n'a pas suivi
toujours les Américains et sur la et sur
l'énergie on n'est pas la même position
non plus même si les Américains
souhaitent que là pour le coup les
Européens et la même position que sur
l'énergie oui oui mais pour l'instant
c'est difficile parce que on a d'abord
27 États et on a c'est facile pour les
Américains de dire on fait un embargo vu
qu'ils sont très autonomes alors que
nous on a des pays on a des pays
européens mais justement l'indépendance
elle est là pendant stratégique et sous
une indépendance énergétique on a pris
des décisions aujourd'hui qui sont aussi
très courageuses puisqu'il y a des états
qui sont à plus de 89% dépendant du gaz
et du pétrole russe l'Allemagne l'Italie
et donc ils vont deux fois plus cher
il faut le prévoir justement ce qu'on a
des mesures c'est pas le pétrole
aujourd'hui c'est le pétrole de l'hiver
prochain et donc on a justement un
créneau pour le faire avant et on va
aider tous ceux qui ont besoin d'être
aidé et je trouve que c'est bien de le
faire maintenant et pas d'attendre
l'hiver prochain où on ne fait on aura
des besoins énergétiques importants
l'Europe va souffrir le fait qu'elle
accepte de souffrir montre le sérieux
qu'elle met dans l'application de ses
sanctions et elle dit vous vous n'allez
pas souffrir vous les Américains et bien
nous allons le faire quand même les
Américains vont souffrir aussi en tout
cas c'est ce qu'a dit Joe Biden alors
moi parce qu'effectivement alors ils
sont dépendants 3% des importations
américaines donc c'est peu donc les
Européens vont souffrir davantage et ils
vont acheter du gaz américain et du
Pétrole américain aussi oui ou non
vis-à-vis de la Russie comment on est en
guerre il faut bien trouver d'autres
moyens américains
énergétique qui sont posées puisque là
on va reprendre encore une spécifique
française je dis qu'il y a une
spécialité française vis-à-vis de l'OTAN
il y en a une en matière énergétique
puisque nous avons fait le choix du
nucléaire ce que n'ont pas fait d'autres
États et qui nous rend aujourd'hui en
effet beaucoup moins dépendant de la
Russie et puis vous avez en effet tout
est transition qui est en cours ou en
effet on doit diversifier et pour ne
plus avoir besoin des énergies fossiles
à long terme voilà à long terme comme
vous dites toute la question
Jean-François dit méglion dit béglio une
question court terme est-ce que
effectivement la Russie est prête à
faire face à ce type de sanction donc
ces sanctions americano européenne en
s'appuyant justement sur la Chine mais
la Chine ne peut pas remplacer les
marchés européens ce qui ce qui est ce
qui est intéressant dans dans ce débat
c'est qu'effectivement il y a cette
montée indéniable de l'économie
stratégique européenne néanmoins avec ce
basculement vers l'Asie des centres
économiques mondiaux on a aussi tendance
à oublier que le marché qui intéresse
tout le monde qui intéresse les
Américains qui intéressent les Chinois
qui intéressent d'une certaine façon les
Russes c'est le marché européen où est
la richesse elle est encore en Europe et
donc cette richesse malheureusement elle
est contredite elle est menacée par
justement cette insécurité énergétique
parce que autant nous allons faire des
efforts autant effectivement on va
construire une autonomie stratégique y
compris dans le domaine de l'énergie
autant nous ne faisons pas les prix et
donc cette souffrance que l'Europe va
être obligée d'affronter c'est aussi la
souffrance d'être incapable de
totalement maîtriser les prix donc la
Chine effectivement ne suffira pas à la
Russie va essayer tout de même est-ce
qu'ils vont renforcer cet accord
manifestement il va la Chine va importer
c'est bien cela du gaz
il faut aussi des moyens unique on ne
décide pas du jour au lendemain qu'on va
importer du gaz il faut que les gazoduc
soit en place un gazoduc c'est pas un
tuyau qu'on va installer du jaune il
faut du temps pour l'installer on parle
de volume qui n'ont rien à voir un
multiple de 1 à 4 du gaz russe qui va
vers l'Europe par rapport à ce qui va
vers la Chine aujourd'hui il y a eu un
très gros contrat effectivement mais il
a mis 20 ans à être négocié ce contrat
de gaz entre la Chine et la Russie parce
que la Chine a attendu que la Russie ait
besoin effectivement de signer avec la
Chine entre-temps effectivement les prix
ont explosé les prix sont sont colossaux
et encore aujourd'hui on a eu une
flambée des prix du gaz et là
effectivement l'Europe qui est à la fois
cette cible et ce marché que tout le
monde veut c'est aussi le marché que
tous les autres vont faire souffrir donc
il y a un vrai danger aussi pour
l'Europe dans cette crise merci de
rappeler pardon j'ai unique et le marché
intérieur c'est la zone la plus riche du
monde
chez loin qui ne veulent pas plus que
nous dépendre de des matières premières
russes sont allés acheter à peu près
tout le gaz qui pouvait trouver en Asie
en Asie centrale et s'intéresse non
seulement au Turkménistan mais dans
d'autres pays et s'intéresse au grand
projet de hub energetics de la Turquie
qui permettra de relier l'est et l'ouest
jusqu'au jusqu'à la pénétration
c'est un allié de la Russie comme tous
les alliés ce sont des gens qui
défendent leurs intérêts on va pas leur
reprocher je voudrais quand même juste
pardon conforter ce que ce que vous
venez de dire qui est extrêmement
important c'est moi ce que moi j'ai du
mal avec le déclinisme européen
permanent c'est que l'Union européenne
est aujourd'hui le premier partenaire
commercial et le premier investisseur
étranger en Chine en Russie et aux
États-Unis alors qu'on ne viennent pas
nous expliquer que l'Europe est une
petite puissance l'Europe est une grande
puissance qui doit assumer les risques
que vin qui vont avec le fait d'être une
grande puissance économique et
financière et commerciale elle va
construire les autres éléments de la
puissance c'est ce que le concept
d'autonomie stratégique vise à faire et
c'est peut-être que cette guerre en
Ukraine provoque aujourd'hui en tout cas
accélère Adrien
indéniablement elle s'en doute elle sera
en face c'était vraiment ce sont des
pays qui sont quand même très divisés
aujourd'hui effectivement
économique très importantes et une
puissance économique ou c'est
l'Allemagne qui donne le temps parce que
c'est la première puissance économique
du continent et c'est une Europe
largement allemande quand on regarde les
marchés donc c'est pour ça que la
diplomatie d'ailleurs ce mot diapason et
que les sanctions elles se elles suivent
finalement la position allemande c'est
parce qu'effectivement la Scholtz a
tourné kazak que on a pu avancer et les
Allemands vont réussir à se débarrasser
justement à devenir autonome à se
débarrasser de cette dépendance de gaz
russe en si peu de temps fermé des
centrales nucléaires et en même temps
dire qu'on va on va plus avoir de gaz ou
alors c'est le réchauffement climatique
qui va exploser parce qu'ils vont faire
ils vont construire des centrales à
charbon vont payer extrêmement cher leur
chauffage l'année prochaine et quand on
dit oui on va souffrir c'est pas grave
madame tout le monde
comme tout le monde qui qui paye son gaz
et son électricité qui va voir sa
facture doublée ou triplée voir
quadrupler dans les prochaines années
faudra peut-être aussi lui poser la
question je suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
d'accord avec nous c'est ça parce
qu'elle journée à vous parler
effectivement de démocratie européenne
qui prend la décision d'augmenter les
prix de d'interrompre cette dépendance
légale
avec effectivement
si vous voulez si on a si on veut en
effet reprendre la main sur son avenir
vous pouvez pas avoir en effet qu'un
fournisseur de gaz qu'un fournisseur de
de de de de pétrole donc il faut bien
diversifier les choses donc il faut le
prévoir donc on va on a décidé qu'en
effet tous ensemble parce que c'est les
27 c'est pas que la fouille avec des
différences entre une Allemagne
dépendante à 55%
elle a peut-être fait des choix
l'Allemagne qu'elle va regretter d'avoir
en effet il y a 10 ans changer le
nucléaire parce qu'il y avait eu
Fukushima et puis que on se et puis
qu'on remet des Chantal à charbon
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a des vers qui
disent non il faut faire autrement donc
en effet elle est pas toute blanche
l'Allemagne mais on a décidé en effet
que petit à petit et dans la dans la
progressivité on allait se désir enfin
être plus moins dépendant de la Russie
donc on va trouver d'autres fournisseurs
on va faire des changements il y a tout
un agenda qui était déjà sur la table
qui va être accéléré et tout le monde
est d'accord même ceux qui sont les plus
tenues par la Russie mais on peut pas
avoir la guerre et dire que ce pays ne
fait des choses mauvaises et être là lui
dit donne-moi du gars s'il te plaît non
c'est pas possible
l'Europe nous a pas échappé c'est
considérablement d'été ces deux
dernières années il y a une inflation
qui commence à être galopante donc là on
va rentrer dans un laflation terrible
beaucoup d'endroits et pas est-ce qu'on
est prêt à déclencher une crise
économique mondiale
pour parce qu'on veut pas faire la paix
en
ukraineiens
ski s'il accepte la totalité de mes
conditions vous appelez ça des
négociations il faut être deux pour
négocier moi j'ai passé mon temps à
négocier avec des Russes quand j'étais
en Bastien en Russie quand Vladimir
Poutine avait l'Ukraine et dit je
détruirai l'Ukraine je expliquez-moi
comment je vais aller faire pour
négocier moi en tant que diplomate si
Vladimir Poutine ne comprend pas qu'il a
déjà perdu
donc si on n'arrive pas à la guerre
maintenant effectivement on pousse les
Ukrainiens
ils veulent ils veulent justement
montrer que ce pays existe puisque ce
pays existe il y a une identité il y a
une langue il y a une langue qui n'est
pas du tout le Russe si vous êtes euh
donc imaginez que vous votre pays soit
agressé oui mais ils vont dire vous
auriez pas que des amis extérieurs vous
aide ils viennent vous apporter plutôt
que il vous disent ben allez
on va positionner en guerre on va pas
vous aider de façon
on fait pas la guerre mais on les aide
justement est-ce que est-ce que les
sanctions est-ce que les sanctions
économiques est-ce que les livraisons
d'armes à l'Ukraine vont suffire
effectivement à faire plier Vladimir
Poutine on va écouter justement le
président américain Joe bidon à ce sujet
les Russes avancent et cela à un prix
énorme mais il faut être clair le fait
que l'Ukraine ne sera jamais une
victoire pour Poutine il peut prendre
une ville mais ne pourra jamais tenir le
pays et si nous ne répondons pas à
l'attaque de Poutine contre la paix les
stabilité du monde et bien il y aura
davantage de souffrance
l'Ukraine ne sera jamais une victoire
pour Vladimir Poutine Adrien des uns
donc ça va suffire ces sanctions
économiques le fait qu'effectivement que
l'Europe va souffrir non mais il y a un
calcul cynique qui pourrait dire
laissons laissons les Américains les
virus pardon s'enfermer en Ukraine dans
une guerre larvée de guérilla qui va
durer 10 20 ans 20 ans et comme ça on va
les battre comme ça à l'usure vous voyez
comme comme quand ils sont allés en
Afghanistan dans les années 80 où on a
alimenté la guérilla on a fourni des
armes et puis on les a laissé finalement
s'enfermer dans un bourbier mais est-ce
que est-ce que c'est vraiment ce que
nous voulons en Ukraine moi c'est la
question que je pose moi je pense
en rentrant en Ukraine il a fait une
fausse stratégie parce que
il il forme la nation ukrainienne contre
lui il a il a renforce quelque part dans
son sentiment national et dans sa haine
des Russes qui était déjà assez élevé
donc pour moi c'est une fausse
stratégique qui a fait donc il faut
qu'on revienne à la raison et que et que
à la fois les Russes et les Ukrainiens
arrivent à s'entendre et à faire la paix
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
j'enregistre pas il faut que Vladimir
Poutine revienne à la raison moi mon
point de vue il est extrêmement simple
ce sont les Ukrainiens qui doivent
décider de l'avenir de l'Ukraine je
trouve extraordinaire qu'on vient de
nous expliquer
plus d'applications
de sortir du commandement intégré de
l'OTAN puis d'y revenir elle a estimé
que c'était son droit légitime au nom de
quoi les Ukrainiens n'auraient-ils pas
le même droit de demander l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne voire de demander la
vision à l'OTAN ce qu'ils n'ont
d'ailleurs pas fait depuis le début de
la guerre sauf erreur de ma part
et si nous sommes respectueux de la
démocratie nous sont justement rompre
avec cette pratique Stalino poutinienne
et de la doctrine qui consistait à dire
moins russe j'ai le droit de décider
pour mes voisins et bien c'est cela
contre quoi l'Europe aujourd'hui c'est
rebeller nous avons trouvé d'autres
façons après le second conflit mondial
de régler nos problèmes entre nous nous
avons créé cette union européenne et
dire aujourd'hui il faut que Céline ski
négocie avec Poutine qu'en Poutine dit
je négocierai que si vous acceptez
toutes mes conditions comme l'a dit très
justement le ministre des Affaires
étrangères
humanitaires
il faut arrêter de prendre les
Ukrainiens pour ceux qui ne se sont pas
ils ont montré un courage on est à côté
d'eux parce que nous sommes à côté mais
vous le dit voudrait plus il a encore
dit aujourd'hui à la Chambre nous sommes
à côté d'eux et la réponse européenne je
pense que il est très content de l'avoir
parce que elle n'était pas gagné
d'avance et donc on a en effet fait pour
l'Ukraine et on va peut-être continuer à
faire parce que vous avez on en a pas
parlé toute une toute une série 4 qui le
voisin de l'Ukraine géographie et qui
aujourd'hui accueille tous les réfugiés
on va pas les fermer la frontière pour
dire rentrez chez vous on va revenir on
n'a pas le temps de revenir sur la crise
des réfugiés allez-y je pense qu'on a on
a enterré un peu vite quand même le rôle
d'arbitre mais d'arbitre actif que la
Chine peut jouer parce qu'effectivement
on a eu tendance à mettre en évidence
les dissensions qui pouvaient y avoir
entre les intérêts chinois et les
intérêts russes néanmoins il y a un
intérêt chinois qui est très fort c'est
de laisser durer cette guerre et d'aider
sporadiquement graduellement la Russie a
tenir parce que plus la Russie tiendra
elle s'affaiira aussi et puis elle
s'affaiblira et puis c'est aussi
l'intérêt de la Chine d'avoir un client
et d'avoir un c'est paradoxal de le dire
aujourd'hui un quasi vassal dans un bloc
qui se constituerait autour de la Chine
et c'est là qu'effectivement cette
guerre en Ukraine peut terriblement
servir la Chine et ce à quoi il nous
faut être vigilant aussi en tout cas on
voit bien qu'il y a une sorte de
redistribution des cardio-politiques
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
Adrien des eaux merci à vous Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur Jean-Maurice Ripert merci
Jean-François diméglio merci Pascal
Jouannin merci à Gwendoline de Bono qui
était avec nous en début de l'émission
au début de l'émission à Odessa en
Ukraine et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis restez avec nous
[Musique]